I don't know if I like the word
coordination to deal with it I think
that will the for example one of the
things that the brain needs to do is
regulate a variety of aspects of our
metabolism so for example it's
absolutely essential that the pH of our
internal miliar be maintained in the
very tight borders above which and below
which it will not operate we simply die
there are certain levels of certain
molecules that have to be maintained
tightly within certain values and you
have sensors in structures for example
like the hypothalamus that are
constantly measuring the level and if
the level that is currently occurring in
your internal me leah is getting
dangerously close to the limit then the
brain immediately generates a response
that is going to be corrective take for
example what happens if what the the
level of water is diminishing because
for example you took a meal that was
very salty you will very rapidly develop
a thing called thirst now thirst is a
very conscious expression of the fact
that their sensor is going like crazy
saying water to low water to low water
too low make a correction and then you
go and drink and of course in go back to
the squirrel the squirrel is not going
to have a very conscious notion of
thirst I need water and let alone
expressing it in words the the squirrel
is going to have that feeling of thirst
and is going to make the correction by
it's starting to search for water even
if the squirrel doesn't do it
liberally is not thinking now I'm going
to need to look for a river or a lake
that is unlikely to happen although I've
never been inside the squirrels mind but
that is there that there's the detection
of the wrong set point and the shooting
off of an order to generate a response
and the response is going to be in the
form of a yearning for water and in our
case not only do we feel it but then we
start translating all of that in very
complex concepts and words and we will
for example if you're in the middle of
the street and you start thinking where
am I going to get water am I going to
get into a restaurant is there water
fountain or whatever so that's a very
complex way of dealing with that but
basically at the core the response is
all being operated you use the word
coordinate that I don't think the word
coordinate is right there it's really a
way of creating a response for what is a
detected in balance is the detective in
balanced by the way of a function that
is called homeostasis so you need to
maintain on your stasis that's critical
and it operates exactly the same same
way for a single cell or for
multicellular organism like we are